thank you uh thank you for having us
we're excited to be here as mentioned uh
my name is Zach I'm the founder of nomad
and we are building a Global co-living
ecosystem for people like you and
me our goal is to make it seamless for
Humanity to live and work anywhere uh
hopefully helping us return to some of
the best parts of our nomadic Roots
which would include spending lot more
time in nature spending more time with
our communities and families going to
wherever nature culture and governments
treat us well all while working on
whatever we want or for whomever we want
around the world thanks to the digital
Revolution and many of the companies and
Technologies such as a couple of the
these listed here it is becoming more
and more possible all of the time to
live and work pneumatically you all know
this very well but Co did not create
this trend it certainly helped
accelerate it uh and educate the world
on the possibilities of remote work
personally I've been living this
lifestyle for 10 plus years I've lived
and worked in 65 countries and what
we've learned is that while it is
possible it is nowhere near
seamless for example how many of you
have shown up in the middle of the night
uh looking for your short-term rental on
a street that looked like this and you
couldn't locate your listing or your
lockbox maybe couldn't contact the host
only to make it inside and find that the
internet sucks you can't take an
important phone call this is just one of
the many examples of the challenges of
traveling and working remotely we've
broken these down into three key
categories uh beginning with consistency
so as mentioned personally I love Airbnb
uh but they do lack consistency in terms
of their accommodations their check-in
processes and and often their
amenities second convenience on the flip
side of the coin many of you guys are
staying in hotels today the process is
incredibly consistent everybody knows
how hotels work but they are not
convenient in the sense that if you were
to stay there for longer than a week Not
only would it cost a fortune especially
in a city like Amsterdam uh you don't
have access to a kitchen probably don't
have comfortable workpace certainly
couldn't bring a bunch of friends or
family to stay over with you so that
leads us to our last one Community or
lack thereof regardless of whether or
not you are a nomad loneliness is an
epidemic between 20 and 30% of us claim
to feel lonely almost all of the time
and it also happens to be the number one
complaint amongst the nomadic or
long-term remote work Community can be
incredibly isolating to travel um uh and
work remotely especially if you're doing
it solo so without addressing these
three challenges the nomatic lifestyle
is unsustainable for the vast majority
of the population therefore it's
inaccessible which is why we started
Nomad so Nomad is a global decentralized
living platform allowing people like you
and me to seamlessly live and work well
anywhere and how are we going to do this
well to start by building a Global
Network of membership access co-living
Villages and individual satellite
locations scattered throughout the
globe our developments are consistent
they're convenient and they come with a
global digitally connected community of
entrepreneurs remote workers and
Builders we're building accommodation
for the modern Nomad a place to stay for
those who love to
move now all of this sounds very
ambitious and grandiose um it's very
easy in the space to have really big
ideas but how are we going to execute on
it so we've broken it down into small
and obtainable steps beginning with a
single point which we dub the
node the node is our Flagship living
product that will act as the building
block for our co-living Villages and
individual uh satellite locations around
the
world it is a compact minimalist
sophisticated unit that has everything
you need for comfortable long-term
living and a little bit more like
surround sound heated floors 12T tall or
4M tall ceilings space shifting uh rooms
with disappearing beds multiple work
stations and
more everything from the fixtures
furnishes
finishes
appliances um all the way down to the
utensils towels and sponges were either
designed or curated by an award-winning
team of Architects interior designers
and Builders uh for the sole purpose of
flexible living and working from
home so now that we've covered our base
product uh are Villages so this is my
favorite part about the
model uh we want to have co-living
villages in every Nomad Hub around the
world where you'll pay one rent and you
can live in any of the locations no
minimum or maximum leasing
terms and we have made real progress in
this space so we've actually closed on
our first two Village locations and
pulled permits on both of them uh the
first one we've broken ground in Raleigh
North Carolina which is where we're
headquartered we have over a 100 plus
paying members there and the second we
actually closed on this weekend while in
Amsterdam with prospera who are here
today day uh they had me sweating
because I we submitted this presentation
weeks ago we were finalizing details uh
2: a.m. last night but we will be build
building a co-living village on an
island in the
Caribbean soon so I will they're going
to be speaking today and they're here so
I'll let them brag about their own
project but I will brag a little bit for
them so Raton is one of the in my
opinion most underated destinations in
the world it has some of the most cryst
blue Caribbean
Waters uh has best diving in the Western
Hemisphere great restaurants nightlife
infrastructure from someone who travels
a lot uh I recommend you making it out
there we will be hosting a Meetup next
year as well Raleigh on the other hand
is just a quintessential American city
mid-tier Tech Hub that a lot of people
are moving to from places like SF and
New
York and in fact one of our investors
happens to own one of the most iconic
buildings in downtown and has offered to
fund the renovation of two of the floors
for a social lounge and co-working space
uh for our members while we anticipate
the construction of our first few
Villages now we just need something that
ties it all together and helps us
achieve the global coverage that we are
looking for which brings us to our
Network so the network consists of our
membership um our Villages and our these
individual satellite locations I keep
referring
to our goal is to have 10,000 locations
on the map by the end of the decade
which would sound insane had we not uh a
couple of months ago announced that
we're licensing the design of our node
plans to people so that anyone including
any anyone in here can own their own on
our
Network whether it's for for a personal
residence an investment property in Adu
we allow slight
customizations uh we want to maintain
that
consistency but this provides us an
asset light way to scale an asset heavy
model and it is making us legitimate
money currently we do have locations
coming soon all over the world um these
are just a few
examples uh we have everything uh from
tropical Costa Rica to the Smoky
Mountain
uh to regular American
backyards last but not least our
membership model uh so these are the
people who will be staying in our
Villages uh and remote locations we meet
up once per quarter somewhere around the
world prototyping this Grand global
vision of having locations all over we
scout out the next locations together
and we would love to have you guys
involved so if you are interested uh in
potentially joining uh please just come
talk to myself or hardic fortunately
Ryan couldn't make it we'll be wearing
uh Nomad hoodies today uh we're looking
forward to connecting with you but if
not uh and especially if you're
online just go to Nomad nation.co
networkstate uh you can subscribe you
can learn more about our memberships
owning your own node uh also you can
follow us on X or Twitter at Nomad
coiv and that's all so thank you guys I
will be playing this video on the way
out uh but I'm looking forward to uh
meeting all of you thank
you